les obscénités vous êtes concentré je
suis concentré vous êtes conseiller les
concentrés comme on dit chez nestlé
alors je vais vous demander votre
qualité de me dire quel est le signe
zodiacal de monsieur et le sud sous le
double signe zodiacal du lion et du
phoque sa balle de bris il est son
caractère impulsif et simultanées oui
ils sont à venir
monsieur a son avenir devant lui mais il
aura dans le dos chaque fois qu'ils
vendent mais tous il est génial
il est absolument génial voulez-vous me
dis là plaisr qu'ils élucident zodiacal
de mademoiselle base elle est née sous
le triple signe bénéfiques de la vierge
du taureau et du sagittaire avant de
s'en servir et quel est son avenir
conjugale et prolifique jolie fille que
l'on a des enfants
oui et des jumelles des jumelles
combien une paire voilà avec avec la
courroie et les tuer il est merveilleux
il voit tout et c'est tout pour sénilité
voulez-vous me dire la plaisance et quel
est le signe zodiacal de monsieur
leptine mercurochrome quelles sont ses
goûts et messieurs allez vous sportif
sportif quel est son sport préféré je
pense qu ça il peut le pratiquer sans
inconvénients oui à condition toutefois
de se méfier se méfier de qui de quoi
le septième personne dans son entourage
qui pourrait penser que sa compétence
dans le domaine de la [ __ ] pour est
exercé une influence fâcheuse ce son
comportement sentimentale et qu'est ce
que vous lui conseiller lui conseille de
changer de braquet de surveiller son
élan
évidemment ce n'était pas plaisant dit
quoi et quelle est la taille de monsieur
1 m 78 de boue ont fait 56 assis avec 45
à plat ventre et 0 mètre quatre-vingt
deux roulés en boule à relever et il
pèse combien de fois par mois s'il joue
demain et goodman son poids rx ne parle
pas bien français 78 kg sans eau sans
galeizon d'électricité est bon oui quel
est son degré d'instruction secondaire
il avait dû plum
oui monsieur licenciés licenciés ils
changeaient glc qui signifie qu'ils
travaillent aux galeries lafayette et
qu'on l'a foutu à la porte
ap les à proximité vous me dites
j'oublie combien madame at-elle dedans
rentrer dedans et 2 2 s'est pas fait
vous me direz
quelle est la nationalité de madame en
fait il est son père eskimos et sa mère
rochette surpris et ta soeur blanchard
et balbin travail est passé par oh oui
aux insolences ou prix mal élevés
escrocs regard site et concentrez-vous
un peu je vous trouve bien dilué tout un
tueur
les chaleurs qui fait pas étonnant pour
ses idées est-ce que je peux continuer à
vous poser des questions ou des ventes
aux usa et messier tout aussi que voilà
at il des complexes
oui monsieur vers un complexe tel
complexe certains moments il prend sa
vessie pour une lanterne
et alors héloïse bruay fait pas ses
nuits à présent quelque chose de très
très très important pouvez-vous dire le
numéro de la carte d'identité de
monsieur oui vous pouvez le dire oui
vous pouvez le dire oui